In the previous video, we finally made
our car move and now we are going to
make a turn, improve on that, and play
around with simple drift mechanics just
for
fun. So, let's start. There are two main
ways you can steer a raycast car. The
first one is to completely fake out the
physics. In this way, when the arrow
keys are pressed, you directly apply
torque to the car to turn it and then
put some forces to stop and control the
car's drift. You also need to
dynamically control how much torque is
applied based on the car speed so it
doesn't turn without speed. This method,
while not realistic, is very commonly
used due to how easy it is to adjust the
drifting. But we are not going to use
that. Instead, we are going with the
second method. This one simulates how
our real car physics work. So, we just
have to rotate the wheels and let the
physics take over and turn the car for
us. It works by applying forces on the
wheel itself based on how much the wheel
is pointing towards the movement of the
car. So here when the wheels rotate, we
apply the red lateral force to the tire.
The more not aligned it is with the
speed of the car, the yellow arrow, the
higher this force. That is the direction
the tire wants to resist movement that
it doesn't want to roll. And we can also
apply the blue arrow force to calculate
the wheels friction to stop the car
instead of how it did previously. This
way of applying forces is well
documented in real cars. The red arrow
force, for example, is called the
cornering force or side force. And we
can find a whole graph showing this
named cornering stiffness which is the
ability of the tire to resist
deformation. This graph will show how
much lateral force a real tire produces
based on the slip angle which is how
many degrees the tire is pointing off
the movement direction. And you can also
find the same for what is called
longitudinal tire force which represents
the blue arrow that is pushing backwards
and resisting the rolling. In real cars,
these graphs can change a lot due to the
temperature, load, tire deformation, and
much more. So, while we won't get quite
as precise, we are going to use some of
the same principles to apply our forces.
So, let's get started. But first, let's
fix the wheel rotation. You might notice
that the wheels are the opposite of what
we want. The big wheel is rotating
faster than the smaller one. So, in the
wheel acceleration function, I got
confused and made a mistake here. To
make the wheels turn correctly, you just
need to divide the velocity by the
radius of the
wheel. Now, that's done. Let's really
start. First, let's remove our
deceleration
code. We'll make the car. We will stop
the car with the simulated friction now,
which makes it easier to adjust the grip
over different types of
terrains. And just so we are back to the
default settings, let's reenable the
default linear damp, which will make the
cart lose velocity and stop with time.
We can remove this damp just for the car
in the rigid body later if we need to.
And let's not forget to remove the
deceleration variable.
Now go to project settings, input map,
and let's set the action turn right and
turn
left. Click on the plus button and add
the A key for the left and D key for the
right action. And you can also add the
arrow keys if you want to. Now let's add
a new variable called tire turn speed to
tell how fast the tires turn in radians
and tire max turn degrees to tell how
much our steering tires can turn in each
direction.
create a new function called basic
steering rotation that will turn our
wheels. We then create a var turn input
which is the input get axis of the turn
left and turn right actions. This will
give us a value between minus1 and one
depending on how much each of the inputs
are pressed and we'll multiply that by
the tire turn
speed. And if we have any turn input we
rotate the wheels. So let's drag the
front left wheel for now and change its
rotation. to be clamp f of the current
rotation plus the turn input time delta.
And we clamp the values between the tire
max turn degrees after converting it to
radians. And then we do the same for the
front right
wheel. And if there is no input, we want
to return the wheel to the start
rotation. So we set the rotation.y of
which wheel with the move toward
function moving it from the current
rotation to zero by the rotation speed.
Then we just need to call the function
in the physics
process. And you can now use the turn
keys to rotate the wheels. But right now
it doesn't do anything. And we are still
hard coding which wheels need turning
which is not good. But we'll fix that
later. To make the car turn, let's
create a new function named do single
wheel traction that takes a raycast
wheel. And if the ray is not colliding,
we return. Here's where we'll add the
lateral and friction forces over the
wheels. For this to work, it's important
to have the wheels ray cast correctly
rotated. You can check their local
rotations by toggling the local
transform button and selecting each
recast. You need to have the brad arrow
pointing towards the side of the tire.
Now back to our
code. We can get the steer side
direction, the local x-axis of the wheel
with the array. global basis.x, X the
global tire velocity with our get point
velocity of the wheel and the steering X
velocity the local velocity of the tire
X-axis with the steer side direction dot
dot product of the tire velocity. Now
that we have all the information we want
we will also declare a X direction of
1.0. This is going to be how grippy our
tires currently are. Now to properly
calculate the lateral force we need to
remember a common physics formula. Force
equals mass time acceleration which we
can change to force domass time the
variation of velocity over time. So to
get our force we need to calculate our
desired acceleration which is the
lateral velocity of the wheel time our
grip x direction divided by delta time.
And our x force is going to be minus the
steering side direction time the desired
acceleration time the mass divided by 4.
The number of our wheels. The mass in
the formula is the tire mass that
represents the load of the car the tire
is supporting. So if you want to get
really precise, you could probably use
the spring compression and the center of
mass to try and figure out the exact
dynamic mass needed. But that's a bit
overkill for our simulation. And the
results are not that much different. In
fact, we don't even need such physics
intensive calculations. We just need to
have some value that loosely gives us
lateral forces based on how the wheels
are turned. So I ended up using a
different value that I found works quite
well. So my X force is actually minus
the steering side direction time the
steering X velocity time the weight the
mass time the gravity divided by 4 the
amount of wheels and we can get the
gravity from the project settings with
project settings dot get setting default
gravity. Now all that's left is apply
the forces. So just like before our
force position is the wheel global
position where you want to apply the
force minus the riged body global
position and call apply force passing
the X force and the force
position. Then you can call a debug draw
if you have one to draw the force
arrows. Now we just need to call our new
function with the others in the physics
process and our car
turns. But if we fully accelerate it
flips. There's a couple of reasons for
that. One reason is that our wheels are
turning really fast and really far at
high speeds, making the sudden changing
forces very drastic. Another reason is
that our back wheels are bigger and we
are using them to accelerate, making it
easier to flip. So, if you select the
back wheels and disable the is motor and
select our front wheels, making them
accelerate
instead, the car is now much harder to
flip.
But let's go back and make it drive from
the back wheels
again. To fix this flip problem, select
all of the wheels and let's give them
the slightest bit of overextend. This
will extend the spring recast and push
our car towards the ground, making it
harder to flip. And now our car is
almost impossible to flip. Even at high
speeds, you need to try really hard to
make it roll. You can play around with
these values and make the car feel the
way we want to, making it impossible to
flip or more realistic and prone to
flipping at high speeds. You can also
improve the wheel turning and make it
turn slower at high speeds. This way, it
will feel more realistic and will not
flip the car as easily. But this all
depends on what type of game you want to
make. Another change you can do is
instead of applying a lateral force to
the wheels local X-axis, you apply
directly to the car's local X-axis. You
can do that by using the minus global
basis.x. This is less realistic, but it
will make your car turn much more
responsively. This way you have more
control in adjusting the handling of the
car and compress the springs more while
turning. It might be a good choice for
some types of arcade racing games. But
let's undo that and go back to our
realistic forces. And now let's add
friction to our wheels which is by
applying a local Z force towards the
back of the tires. We can get the tire
local forward direction with minus ray.
global basis dot dotproduct of the tire
velocity. And we declare the Z direction
of 0.05. 05 how much traction each wheel
has. And our final Z force is the global
basis Z time the F velocity time the Z
direction traction times the tire
weight. You can also use the rate.global
basis.z here instead of the car's global
basis to a more realistic traction force
which can affect the handling depending
on how the wheels are steered. But I'm
going with the simpler approach here of
just reducing the speed in the car's
direction. Then like before we call
apply force, but this time with the Z
force. Now our car stops faster anyways.
But because we are now fighting with
attrition, our car will accelerate
slower. So you need to adjust the
acceleration if you want to keep the
same speeds as before. Now you can use
the type of terrain the tire is on to
adjust the Z traction, but we'll play
with that later. Our turning is still
very far from realistic. So we'll fix
that. But first, let's try to add a
handbrake action to our car and make it
drift.
and we'll use the space key for
that. We'll add a new variable called
handbreak and set it to false. And in
our input function, we'll check if the
handbreak action is
pressed. And if it is, we set the
handbreak action to
true. When it's
released, we set it to
false. Now, here's what we are going to
do. When we press the handbrake key, we
will change the extraction value to a
smaller one and that will make the car
drift. So if the handbrake is true, we
set the extraction to
0.1. And I'll also show a yellow arrow
to show the direction the car is
moving. Now let's try some drifting. It
works, but when we release the button,
the car jerks really
aggressively. That's because it's go
from very little force to a sudden high
force. If you decrease our normal
traction to 0.7, it's a little better.
And reducing it even further to 0.2. Now
it's almost not there. To fix that and
make the car behave more realistic, we
are going to use curves to control how
our traction changed dynamically.
Depending on the slip angle, let's go
over our wheel script and add a new
export variable called grip curve of
type curve. This curve will represent
how much grip the tires have. If you
remember the cornering stiffness graph,
the slip angle is used to tell how
aligned the tire is to the car's speed
direction and the lateral force applied
changes based on that. So, let's start
at 100 grip and then lose almost all the
grip at the end. Let's copy this curve
and paste it in the other wheels. With
these grip curves, you can change how
your car handles and drifts by giving
each wheel a different grip curve. Now,
let's go back to our car and make it
work. We'll get the grip factor the x
value on the curve by getting the
absolute value of the lateral velocity
divided by the velocity's length. And
our extraction is now the ray.grip curve
dot sample baked of that. And now things
are a bit better. But we still got some
strange behavior. We can probably play
around with the curve values and try to
improve that. And talking about that, be
careful when changing these
values. Changing curve values does not
work with multis select. You might think
you changed all of them when in fact you
changed just one. One thing you can do
is copy the curve and paste it over the
others. This will make the paste curve a
reference of the original one. So when
we change one, all of them will also
change. And if you want to make them
different again, you can use the make
unique option. But anyways, with this
new curve now, the car's light is way
too much. So let's adjust that a bit.
Now things are not perfect yet. And one
reason for that is that the tires behave
differently when drifting. But to help
visualize things better, let's create
some simple drift marks for the tires.
Let's give the car a new node 3D and
call it skid marks. And add a new GPU
particle 3D node. Now under the draw
passes, create a new quad mesh. Click to
open it and let's make it face the Y
direction pointing up and create a
material. Now go back up and create a
process material tool. And let's move it
to the side so we can see it. We'll
disable the gravity acceleration so it
just spawns in place. Now when the car
moves, it will keep creating these
squares and they will become our skid
marks. Let's go back to our draw pass
material. Enable alpha transparency and
invertex color enable use as albido.
This will let us change the color of the
mesh with the particles. Now back to the
particle, open display and create a new
color ramp. Open the gradient and let's
make the mark black at the
start. And it's still black at the end,
but with less alpha
transparency, making it vanish over
time. Then let's set the time to
1.5, the FPS to 60, and the amount 150.
And now we got something that look like
skid marks. Disable emitting. And let's
duplicate this three
times. Inside our car script, let's
create a new export variable skid marks
of type array of GPU particle 3D and add
them in in the
inspector. Now let's add an ID variable
and pass it over to the wheel traction
function and increase it at the end of
the loop. This is just so we have a
reference of what skid mark belongs to
what wheel.
Finally, we are going to add a new is
slipping variable and we are going to
set it to true when we first enable our
handbreak inside our wheel traction
function. Let's first position the skid
mark at where the tires hit the ground
and that is just the ray get collision
point and we move it just slightly up so
it doesn't zite with the ground for the
position. Then we rotate the skid marks
to the direction of the car with look at
the current position plus the back
direction of the car.
Let's set the X direction to 0.01 to
lose almost all directionction. And if
the skid mark is not emitting particles,
we enable it drawing the drifting marks.
And to make the transition from the
handbrake more smoothly, we'll check if
the handbrake is released but the car is
still sleeping and set the X direction
to 0.1. And if we are not pressing the
handbrake and the grip factor is less
than 0.2, to meaning the velocity of the
wheel kind of aligns with the car speed
again. We set the isipping to false and
go back to our normal gripping curves
while also disabling the skid
marks. Now the feeling of our car is
much better and the drifting feels
okay. Another thing we can do is make
the skid marks skinnier. So let's open
the draw pass of our particles and set
the X size to
0.6. And now it looks much better. There
are better ways to make skid marks, but
particle skid marks are very simple to
make, and they usually look okay at an
angle. But that's it. Our car can now
steer and even make drifts. There are
still a lot of things we can improve and
fix in our car, but the basics are all
here. Usually, games use two grip
curves, one when driving and another
grip curve for when the car starts
slipping. But we already got so many
curves in this tutorial that I used a
simpler approach here. Our lateral force
calculations here are a bit problematic,
too.
The cornering stiffness usually tapers
off at very low slipping angles, but in
our code, the lateral force curve only
maxes at 90°, which is not ideal. And we
are also using a variable force
depending on the speed of the car
instead of just the angle. So if the car
is really fast, the forces are really
extreme, and that is one of the biggest
reasons of our problems. So we can
probably improve on that. In the next
video, we'll tie everything together,
fixing a few problems and cleaning up
the code. Then we'll finally set our car
with a proper car mesh. And if there is
time, we can talk about a better way to
turn the wheels that is better to
prevent slipping. As always, if you want
to, you can check the project files by
supporting me on Patreon. But that's
really it. You now have all the tools to
play around and start making your own
car feeling the way you want it to. I
hope you have fun making your games and
until next time.